[Music]
well the i-team learning new information
about the ongoing investigations of
voter fraud right here in nevada
that as governor steve sisilak signs a
new law aimed at preventing dead people
from getting ballots our david charns
joins us live in studio with what we
know right now david
well christian the new mail-in voting
law requires the secretary of state's
office to work with other agencies to
now cross-check a statewide active
voter registration list the i-team has
stayed on top of these allegations of
fraud since
back in november for that election we
can confirm there are ongoing
investigations involving cases of dead
registered voters who had a ballot cast
in their names
the i-team finding 10 instances of dead
individuals having votes cast in their
names
one case involves a las vegas woman who
died in 2017. now a ballot was
issued in her name it was later it was
later received by the county
we found though even though she died her
name
appeared on the active voter list
and here's what her husband told us soon
after that
certainly brings up a lot of discomfort
you know there's a pretty exhaustive
process that you go through when someone
passes
now you can see his full comments online
in an unrelated case a las vegas man who
died in 2017 also had a mail-in ballot
cast in his name
officials telling the i-team it appears
his ballot was returned by a family
member who herself
did not vote we reported that back in
november the secretary of state's office
which
again headed by a republican the nevada
supreme court
and several judges say there was no
evidence of widespread voter fraud here
in nevada now republicans actually
gained seats in the state senate and
assembly
with our first wide-scale test of
mainland voting last november where
about
half of people did vote by mail
president joe biden won nevada by about
two percentage points
i'm david charns eight news now